pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux vous connaissez ce légume
c'est un topinambours un tubercule ça
pousse dans le sol comme une pomme de
terre accroché une racine ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas leur seul point commun
les deux viennent du nouveau monde
mais pourquoi topinambour
ce tubercule débarque dans les ports
français au début du xviie siècle
il vient le canada où il est baptisé
jusqu alors artichauts divers au même
moment
six membres d'une tribu brésiliennes
sont embarqués de force sur un navire
pour être présentée au roi de france
louis xiii ces deux événements font
grand bruit dans les villages et à la
campagne ils vont se percuter et se
mélangent les nouveaux venus à la cour
appartiennent à la tribu des tours ou
binôme out
j'espère que je prononce bien il va y
avoir confusion le nom de la tribu va
être donnée aux tubercules et
l'artichaut l'hiver pas devenir un taux
pin up ce légume a été consommée
jusqu'au xviiie siècle avant d'être
boudée au profit de la pomme de terre
les français l'ont redécouvert contre
leur gré sous l'occupation pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale pour remplacer
les pommes de terre qui était alors
réquisitionné puis il a de nouveau été
oubliée avant de refaire surface
on le retrouve depuis quelques années
sur nos étals du mois de novembre au
mois d'avril
le topinambour contient un glucide
dérivé du fructose l'inuline c'est pour
cette raison qu'après avoir consommé du
topinambour
tout ce que l'on boit un goût sucré fait
l'expérience
c'est très étonnant à bientôt si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus merci les épis
curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]